and as Putin made his first comments
since that failed Uprising Ukraine's
president rallied his troops on the
front line Vladimir zielinski praised
his military for what he called sweeping
advances zelenski's office says he spent
the day visiting troops stationed near
bertiansk he thanked the soldiers for
retaking control of settlements in the
area
in all directions our soldiers HUD in
advance and it's a happy day I wish the
boys more days like this I was with the
units of hortizia and they distinguished
themselves in the battle for bakmut
heroically distinguished himself's well
done Warriors
assadbag is covering developments for us
from Kiev hello there I said a positive
tone from the president it would seem
but is that actually being felt on the
ground
well if you listen to the ukrainians
they say they have been making advances
on all fronts and president zielinski
said that it was a happy day now on the
ground on the reality is that those
front lines haven't really changed now
the deputy defense minister said that
the forces made advances of around 17
square kilometers which is about six and
a half square miles and they took a
village in the zapparicha region now
when we hear about these advances it's
not a great deal in reality and when
there are ukrainians say that they've
taken a village the question is what
remains of that Village how many people
actually still live there but like this
conflict has been going on now for a
while both sides pay up any advances
that they make and downplay any losses
now the Ukrainian authorities have said
now they're making a claim that the
Russians have finished preparations or
what they say is a terrorist attack on
the zapparicha plant they're claiming
the Russians have planted explosives
there and now it's important to say that
this hasn't been independently verified
or corroborated but the Ukrainian
authorities say that they have put in
emergency evacuation exercises in the
event of an accident but the Russians
are saying that there is fear there are
Fierce battles taking place in Zappa
region now zaparita region uh is split
uh Russians control part of it but
zaparita City the ukrainians control
that and the Russians control the
nuclear plant so as I said those battles
are ongoing but there hasn't really been
any significant changes in the front
lines Ukraine has released some footage
of a suicide drone a Ukrainian suicide
drone targeting a Russian vehicle in the
east of the country and that battle in
the East continues and we're hearing
from both sides that the battles are
Fierce and the Ukrainian so-called
counter-offensive that we've been
hearing about has been slow in trying to
get those advances and trying to regain
some of that territory Assad thanks so
much for bringing us up to speed
live for us in kids